hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review
time for a review for exchange instead
of uh
technical tutorials and uh the review
product is this hello
streamer if you don't know what a
streamer is uh
when we started to get into computer
audio we ran into a problem which is
how do you get audio from a computer to
your uh
stereo system and one solution is you
can put the computer next to your stereo
then hook up a usb dac to it
and you're in business but then you have
a
dedicated computer sitting next to your
audio system and it's not some most
people want to do
the more typical model is excuse me is
to uh
have a control surface a tablet a phone
or pc
and using the rich user interface on
that
select what you want to play and then
over network instructor
device that's sitting in your stereo to
do the streaming for you
and that can vary depending on
architecture
how you set it up and maybe i'll talk
about that a little bit more
the streamers come most two com
they come to the uh configurations one
that is just digital
which means over ethernet receives its
data stream
and then it has a speedif or usb or some
way for you to hook up your external dac
to it
and this one is actually different
in that it actually has
rca output so it has an internal dac
built in
and the architecture of this is also
unique
in that inside of it there's a raspberry
pi
if you don't know what raspberry pi is
is single board computers
it was made for education it's a little
board
costs 30 40 and you can buy that board
and you can take a little sd card or
micro sd card and put different
operating systems on it
you then you insert that into the micro
sd slot and you boot up
that operand system on that little
computer it goes on a network and that
becomes your
uh communication environment and there
are different canned versions of that
the operand system the linux operating
system
uh volumio diet pie ropey these are all
the different names for
for them each has different support just
about all of them are free
at least in the basic configuration are
free
what's unique about this is that when
you get those products you're on your
own to do the system integration
in that you get a bare board you have to
go find the case
usually you don't find a case this nice
and this metal and
i'm kind of cute and cool looking
this product also has a oled display
and set up menus that are customized to
what you want to do
uh on a device like this you can set the
dac filters and the outputs
uh sp uh voltage and what have you
here's a system info i don't know if
it's going to do anything right now yeah
so it says boss 2 which is the
model number of this device is giving me
the ip network so if you have a browser
you point it at that
and you can communicate this instance is
running
an operating system called diet pie and
the nice thing about diet pie is that if
you have the right modules in it
it uh automatically acts as an endpoint
for roon
player r o o r o o n
which is my favorite player and uh
which means that all i've got to do is
turn this on put it on the network hook
up ethernet to it or you can hook up a
wi-fi dongle
uh in the back and roon instantly
detects it and anything i want to play
as if i'm playing on local dac i can
push to this device
and it will output the bits
to this over network and then this
drives this internal dac
and analog output comes out that you
hook up to a pair of powered speakers if
you want or a standalone amplifier
of your choice and a passive speaker so
it does a lot of integration for you it
gives you a lot of the pieces and moving
parts
um you can hook up hard disks and
thumb drives and put music on them if if
your music you know fits on that and you
rather have it local to this device
you can also do that and there are
players on these things that let you
browse that
and using the browser or some other
remote app
to control it so many different ways of
communicating with these things
the point of this device is that it's a
chameleon it gives you the hardware
system
fully integrated what choice of software
you want to use is up to you
again if you're a roon user best thing
to do is put some image on it that
supports roon and then you don't need to
learn anything new this just becomes a
quick appliance
and you're done i use the roon player
like i always do
on my desktop or on my tablet or my
phone
and everything just works but you can
use other open systems
many of these images come with airplay
support so you can just
use any ios device that you have you can
directly beam
your music to it know that the airplay
is limited to 16 bits
and a 44 kilo sampling so if you try to
play any high-res
files it tends to butcher them not just
pass them through properly
so but for cd music is fine so you can
also use airplay directly out of the box
it gets discovered looks just like any
other airplay device to
your ios device on that so
um i won't get much more into the
functionality of this but just know that
it is quite cool to have something like
this
um let me oh by the way there's also
send me a little send me this uh
fancy power supply even though it's
quite fancy looking only
costs 50 extra so the base box is 149
with this becomes 109. what's nice about
this thing is that it's
earth chess grounding pin is actually
floating and you can choose to ground or
not ground this
and this can be a big help in getting
rid of ground loops
that you might have in your pc um and
this player itself also the streamer
also has an independent ground
and you can play a bit a bit play with
it
uh note that you may get hum out of the
box because everything's floating and
that may actually work against you so
you may need a little jumper wire that
goes from this screw to that
or to the rest of your system and
experiment for my situation where i'm
just testing it
with my analyzer out of the box i had
zero ground loop with this power supply
i did also uh let me see if i can find
it no i don't have it here anymore
i'll just use the standard high power 5
volt usb uh adapter also and tested in
performance
essentially identical but there i got
some ground loops and then once i
grounded things
it all worked great so you don't have to
buy this 50
one you can buy a 15 high power
usb and it needs to have the sort of
this barrel type of connector not a
regular usb connector
there are adapter cables that go from um
usb back to this if they need it but
it's better to buy one
with this but you need two or three amps
of power because the uh
raspberry pi is a full-blown computer
and uses fair amount of power
so you need to have that in there to get
it working
lots of words but reality if you buy the
power supply
from them hook it up just turn it on and
the thing
comes alive so with that why don't we
get into the performance
uh of of this thing
i uh treat this as if it's a network tax
so i wanted my roon player
and i played my one killer's tone as if
my analyzers
talk into it and uh this is the
performance that we get
um the uh distortion is minus 120 db
remember i've said before minus 115
is the absolute threshold of detection
for uh
human uh there's nothing we cannot hear
any tones lower than that
regardless so this is completely
transparent as far as performance the
distortion that you see in here
looks tall in in the measurement but
because the bottom of it is as low as
160 or so and
so you're guaranteed that this the
fidelity is just superb
um the synad which is the sum of these
distortions on noise
it is averages to about 113
so again right at the threshold of
hearing and that lands it
way up here in the as compared to
standalone decks this is a dac
that's inside this little guy with a
little board in there but
it is despite having all the complexity
of a computer sitting right next to it
the noises that that can generate and
everything
is still able to spit out a sign ad that
lands
probably in top 25 of all dax i've ever
tested 25 30.
and uh usually when you buy standalone
desktop deck of
around a hundred dollars this is the
performance you get
and for that hundred dollars you just
get a dac you don't get a computer you
don't get the networking you don't get
the streaming
in there so it is wonderful to be able
to have that level of performance
but already integrated in the streamer
somebody else reviewed this uh hans in
in
netherlands and made a remark that this
sounded good but
it wasn't as good as more expensive
stuff i love to
measure his more expensive stuff that he
has i guarantee you this is
the just superb performance is audibly
transparent
don't listen to people who just seem to
use
dollars of money as as the rating for
performance
measure it if that other device is good
or better than this
okay then there's technically something
better but audibly i guarantee you this
is
you know almost the pinnacle of the
performance you can get despite the
budget class that these devices
um we can measure the dynamic range
um when i measured this i actually
didn't attempt to play with grounding
too much and one channel came out
weaker than the other one um i
didn't realize it was a grounding thing
on the bottom of this till i wouldn't
test it with the other power supply
i'm sure if i tested it with proper
grounding
both channels would be 123 db and
that'll then give you 20
21 bits of uh 20 to 21 bits of dynamic
range so
it's about as good as you can get state
of the art is 21 so
you're almost there with state of the
art and certainly well above
16 bit cd which is about 96 db
um we see some spurious uh tones in here
now jitter test but their levels are
at -140 again anything below
-115 is academic and this certainly is
the case so
it's exceptionally clean from that point
of view around my 32 tone tests for
people who think
you know one or two you know simple test
stones are not representative of music
well
this is actually more complex than music
because that's such a rich spectrum
and you can see that the noise floor is
about -120 worst case
and then it actually gets better and
better to uh minus
uh 130 or so and a couple of spikes in
here but
they're just you know random spikes
there i'm not worried about that so
any way you skin this you have a
resolution to burn so this is
well above uh certainly any cd cds
16-bit
and you need to have a world-class
recording that has
noise floors just good now as always you
want your source to be the cleanest
because all this noise and distortion
adds up
you have the amplifier next and the
speaker next so it's good to
start with as clean as you can and i
always say that you know great
engineering doesn't cost much these days
so
demand great engineering you know you
know we don't have to debate how
audible the distortions are when we know
it's fully transparent
and it costs nothing so you're not
paying a premium to have such a superb
performance
um a little story about this company um
when i started audio science review and
i tested the first
couple of products and nobody knew about
us we a tiny little
um site i got a message from them saying
oh you started test things how about
testing some more decks
and they were making raspberry pi decks
and
i said whoa you know you know what
you're getting yourself into
whatever our tests have to publish and
they may make it look bad and their
answer was
so be it if there's some wrong we want
to find out we want to fix it
and it was so refreshing and turns out
the performance was great they have an
audio precision analyzer like i have so
they test and
properly engineer their products unlike
the other guys many of the uh
even high-end boutique companies who
test and release things based on the
prayer that the stuff measures well and
is prof you know designed well
so they're also active in the forum on
audio songs review
extremely good people a pleasure to work
with them um
just can't say enough good things about
the company no i have no relationship
with them whatsoever
i'm just so satisfied to finally finally
find a stream or product i can recommend
uh people in the comments keep asking me
hey can you tell me how to start with a
you know low cost system and go up um to
the extent you need networking and
streaming
um this is where your starting point 150
if you have your own power supply
otherwise up to 200
you get this and then you decide what
your player strategy is what you want to
use and uh
you could have a very rich system where
you have you know
touch screen touch screens that you use
to control your music
and this can be deployed in different
parts of your home it's very cheap you
can put it in multiple systems
and not apologize for it and it's kind
of cute in the way it looks and
everything uh but
you know you're welcome to hide it too
it's it's not that big
okay so i highly recommend you look into
this there's a good discussion
uh on audio science review thread also
about different capabilities if you're
interested
so with that i will bring that video
this video to an end and see you in a
future one bye